[Musique]
les shadows que d'en bas on construit
une fusée pour partir tout seul de leur
côté cbs scélérate n'avait absolument
aucun sens moral
elle voulait partir pour que la planète
ton
et pour voir la tête que ce dont on
ferait quand il se révélerait avec rien
sous les pieds mais il a fait les mêmes
problèmes que ceux en cours à l'envers
finalement et si la fusée dont ne
voulait pas monter celle d'en bas elle
refusait de descendre et à chaque essai
elle remontait et se cassait il avait
fait appel pour la fabriquer un
spécialiste justement des fusées
cassante
le professeur shadow co lui même que
vous connaissez bien il avait déjà conçu
la fusée dans mo et c'était une parfaite
réussite du point de vue cassage il faut
dire et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
était au groupe
vous vous souvenez que le groupe peut
être une suite de boyaux étroits ou les
shadoks dont on n'était pas
excessivement satisfait étaient invités
à se reposer mais les shadows lambaye
avait creusé des sortes de petites
trappes qui l'ouvraient de parier que
pouvoir les autres tombées ce qui les
amuse et passablement déjà d'autres que
drogba naturellement et il devait dire
shadow cookies leur fallut les plots de
sa fusée sinon il le ferait sortir eu du
boulot et pas du bon côté
jadot coup évidemment avait cédé mais
tout seul lui avait donné une idée
[Musique]